welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen I'm Priyanka and in this
episode we'll share the recipe to plan a
hot D our pattern for your application
that's deployed on-premise so let's dive
it
[Music]
a little recap in the last two episodes
we talked about Main Street art that
runs their applications on premise and
are building a DR infrastructure on
Google Cloud they started with the cold
ER plan and moved to a warm standby due
to the need for lower RTO and RPO values
well now main street art has become
really popular and cannot afford to be
down even for seconds since their
requirements is to achieve a near zero
RTO and RPO values the only way is by
running a che architecture across their
production environment and Google Cloud
concurrently let's see how this works
from the setup perspective we create a V
PC network then we configure the
connectivity between the on-premise
Network and the Google Cloud Network we
create custom images of the servers in
Google cloud with the exact same
configuration as on-premise then
configure the replication between
on-premise database server and the one
on Google cloud remember that if your
database systems permit only a single
writable database instance when you
configure replication then you might
need to ensure that one of the database
replicas act as a read-only server
create individual instance templates
that use the images for the application
server and the web server configure
regional managed instance groups for the
application and web servers then
configure health checks using stat
driver monitoring and load balancing
using the regional managed instance
groups configure a scheduled task to
create regular snapshots of the
persistent disk and lastly configure the
DNS service to distribute traffic
between your on-premise environment and
the Google cloud environment with this
hybrid approach you need to use a DNS
service that supports weighted routing
to the two production environments so
that you can serve the same application
from both in case of a failure on
premise you just disabled the DNS
routing to the on-premise webserver and
that's it in most cases the
DNS service supports health checks and
will automatically route all the traffic
to the healthy servers on Google cloud
and when it is all back to normal and
can handle production traffic we need to
resynchronize the databases if your
database system doesn't automatically
promote a read-only replica to be the
writable primary on failure you need to
intervene to ensure that the replica is
promoted after ensuring that just enable
the DNS routing back to distribute
traffic to both on-premise and Google
cloud well there you have it if you are
running your application on-premise and
are looking to achieve very very small
RTO and RPO values then hopefully you
learned how to approach recovering the
environment from failure using Google
cloud hot h a across the two
environments that's all for today and
get cooking in cloud here's hoping you
are cooking up your own dr strategy join
us next time and learn the recipe to
implement disaster recovery for
applications that are built on google
cloud if you like this video and would
like to see more such content don't
forget to Like and subscribe to our
Channel
[Music]